hey everybody welcome to the great fix
to our YouTube channel I'm Jillian I'm
Dave this is our very good friend
Jeffrey the horse here's the show these
stories are all about writing whether
it's horses bicycles motorcycles you
name it we're going for the first story
we're going to meet some a Geoffrey's
buddies down in Philadelphia here's the
story the horses really do help you with
progression once you own a horse and you
out that's all your mind is on is having
fun
my name is Shai here and I'm a concrete
I work
[Music]
I first got on a horse after I turn 10
and I was young so I was like I like
dead horse I thought it was cool horses
I remember just like that me and shadow
had to combine our tempers and work
together because she's the walk wire
while I was running but dopey balls and
I just obviously get back on her just
ahead of patient when I ride people
actually give me like props and they
actually be applauding me the hooded
guys and everything maybe actually can I
ride you wanna trade people like here
[Music]
when the stable started about 10 years
ago it gave me something to do something
to keep the kids busy with keep him
occupied from running the street get in
trouble and Southwest Philadelphia so a
lot of sense was killing and I try to
give kids something to get away from
stuff like that and when they start
learning with the animals it kind of
calmed down because they teach him they
learn it it helps them out a lot
violence in communities crazy I don't
love a brother uncle lost a lot of
friends but when I work with the horses
like a type of therapy I can have fun
and not worry about everything else
that's going on around yes I would have
never met Malik inside around horses I
probably would and doing stuff that
looks gross we don't get in trouble once
you get to running and having fun it
seemed like all that is forgotten
[Music]
we're going to move from riding horses
to writing the wall of death we're going
to meet Kari and her motorcycle and it
is frightening let's check out her story
the first ride is the straight wall ride
the second act is our go-kart
at full wheel this time third act it's
right in one of these lovely ladies and
when you do hands off stand it up hands
off sitting on the sides standing on the
side as a whole array of that it's an
experience you can't prepare anything
the horses I'm Terry Cameron and iron
wall of death Rider and I ride for Luke
Fox's original wall of death these are
our wild racers after we take you way
back new drivers on exciting exciting I
started riding the wall of death by pure
accident I used to work with horses and
unfortunately where I was working in a
place shut down
so naturally we went the job center and
I just typed in horse rider into the
search engine and well a deaf rider came
up and I went down to the art and they
have the wall built up I knew there and
then that a bit
you do your very simpie when you first
learn to ride you've got buildings down
there up to the dizziness it has to go
at least first email I'll stay on with
wise gravity which is whip you stray off
it's a mixture free thing so balance
speed and I'll see the better stamina
lifting your arm up the wave goodbye for
you is quite a seat is a good feeling
being a female rider in this masculine
environment it gives me a great buzz a
lot of people when they see you walk
into the wall they just think they're a
bit of flash you know but as soon as
they see you get on the bike you can
hear like murmurs they oh there's a girl
on a motorbike see all their faces light
up
and after the show all the girls are
like wow it's got bigger balls and most
of them but but it's right to notice
that there let me rethinking balls if
you can do it then so can I so it's one
thing to race around a wall but quite
another to get on a bike and fly 6,000
feet down ed MacGyver launched in the
French Alps these bikers race down the
mountain let's check it out
[Music]
every year the world's most elite
mountain bikers gather in France for a
race unlike any other of it the longest
untell new race in the world
that's right McGavin launched is the
longest downhill race in the world 18
miles long
10,000 behind the French Alps and a
crazy starting line of 3,000 cyclists on
a mountain peak this is Reverend Al
Kaline he won the mag Avalanche it's at
110 bike when I was young and euro and
mountain bike is really cool because we
can explore all over of the world
Nick Avalon shall for us take place in
the French Arts in Hartford us so not so
far Atari and children
it's the vdi in harps so you have a very
good view when were 60 degrees around
you
it's really crazy I don't know why I do
that
you write all kind of terrain but the
jerky and after the rotations fall it is
very physical with some happen so when
you cross the line and you are first
you're really happy and want to try
again for our next story we're going to
meet Rosalie who is the youngest female
monster truck driver any of you thought
that was impressive she's not just
driving the truck she can also build
them and is trying to make the monster
truck up for dream
here's her a great big story to anyone
who says I'm too young or girls can't do
it I would say come on to Monster Jam
event watch me compete and lost engine
[Music]
I'm Rosalie Rayner at the world's
youngest professional female lost race
car driver when I first sat in the seat
of a monster truck I was 11 I started
competing at age 14 and I've been
competing ever since I could have been
lost to research before I could drive a
car on the road I'm studying mechanical
engineering at Georgia Tech and I'm
working on making the monster truck of
my dreams I'm working on lowering the
center of gravity of the MA stretch so
that has better handling and more
capabilities when we're out there on the
field computing first I got an idea
about how I want to improve a monster
truck then I put some ideas down on
paper and my sketch pad I get to put
that into the computer so I can work
with it on a higher level and I get to
3d print it
having a technical mind is definitely
advantage on the field I know exactly
how my truck works and it allows me to
read how it's doing on the track I can
fix anything that's wrong with my truck
wildflower is the first truck I got to
help build putting that paint those big
flowers on my truck that really shows
Who I am and I'm proud of that and I
hope that that makes little girls to
Dula princesses and who do love flowers
more open-minded through the world of
big trucks and machinery and mechanical
engineering I'm proud of Who I am I am a
woman I Drive a truck thank you so much
for joining us all we watch these for a
great big stories don't forget to
subscribe and comment we'll see you guys
next time